[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka
guten abend dass dieser wahlkampf ein
besonderer werden würde war klar zum
einen hat keiner beziehungsweise keine
der zur wahl stehenden einen
persönlichen kanzleramts bonus und keine
partei kann davon ausgehen locker
zumindest über 30 prozent zu kommen das
macht das ganze zu einem engen rennen
mit offenem ausgang und jetzt kommt
zusehends bewegung in das feld einer der
am anfang eher chancenlos schien schiebt
sich inzwischen mächtig nach vorn auf
die frage wen hätten sie am liebsten als
bundeskanzlerin sprechen sich 44 prozent
für olaf scholz aus das ist ein zuwachs
von 10 prozentpunkten gegenüber dem
letzten politbarometer
die beiden anderen liegen weit dahinter
armin laschet mit 21% er verlor 8 punkte
und auch annalena baerbock hat noch mal
federn lassen müssen sie sind sie liegt
jetzt bei nur 16 prozent minus 4 punkte
gewählt werden aber ja nicht personen
sondern parteien die spd hat aber auch
zulegen können und liegt nun gleichauf
mit den grünen bei der sonntagsfrage
kommt die union auf 26 prozent die spd
auf 19 afd und fdp beide 11 die linke 7
und die grünen 19 bei dieser
konstellation würde eine koalition aus
zwei parteien nicht gelingt es bräuchte
auf jeden fall ein dreierbündnis
das ist natürlich immer nur
momentaufnahmen die jedoch die beiden
anderen kandidaten schwer unter druck
setzen vor allem armin laschet bekommt
das gerade zu spüren wie david gebhard
berichtet
der eine inszeniert sich als mastermind
der e mobilität und will menschen auf
dem mars ansiedeln der andere hat die
mission bundeskanzler zu werden und
stürzt dabei gerade ab in umfragen bei
seinen beliebtheitswerten und so wird
elon musk heute in einer reporterfrage
quasi die rolle als laschet
motivationscoach angetragen sie sind ein
experte für energiefragen laschets
wahlkampf geht gerade der stoff aus
hätten sie einen tipp bei uns geht es
nur um energie wie in dieser fabrik
die miesen umfragewerte verfolgen
laschet in diesen tagen überall hin dass
vermeintliche zug fährt zieht die cdu
gerade eher nach unten doch der
kanzlerkandidat wiegelt ab ich
kommentiere umfrage nicht wenn sie gut
sind und ich kommentiere sie nicht will
sich schlecht sind ich will sie ändern
ich will darauf aufmerksam machen was
auf dem spiel steht je nachdem wer in
deutschland die mehrheit hat hinter
laschet liegen wochen der verunglückten
inszenierung als er als anpacker im
hochwasser rüberkommen will hände in den
hosentaschen
unglückliche bilder vor schrott bergen
und das feixen während der
bundespräsident über die katastrophe
spricht
die zahlen für die union sind nicht gut
da muss man nicht um den heißen brei
reden umso wichtiger ist dass wir jetzt
wirklich schwung in diesem wahlkampf
bringen deswegen müssen wir uns alle
miteinander und an der spitze natürlich
armin laschet jetzt besonders anstrengen
auch ratschläge können schläge seien
selbst in laschet cdu wächst seit tagen
die kritik an der schlechten performance
der union und ein ministerpräsident
sieht mit diesen umfragen die partei an
ihren eigenen ansprüchen scheitern die
stimmung wenige wochen vor der wahl am
tiefpunkt ja ich will ja gar nicht um
den heißen brei herumreden die zeit ist
knapp und wir müssen jetzt in die
offensive kommen und zwar mit voller
wucht es kommt auf alle an nicht nur auf
armin laschet auf alle wir dürfen auch
unsere partei nicht auf einzelne
personen beschränken die union
schwächelt andere wittern morgenluft die
grüne kanzlerkandidatin berbalk hofft
dass ihre eigene pannenserie nun in den
hintergrund rückt doch zumindest ihre
person umfragewerte bleiben schlecht
jetzt geht der wahlkampf richtig los
jetzt geht es eigentlich darum deutlich
zu machen was gibt es für unterschiede
für den part zwischen den parteien und
diese unterschiede sind sehr groß die
einen wollen weitermachen wie bisher wir
treten an ich trete an für eine
erneuerung scholz dagegen liegt bei den
persönlichen werten stark zu zieht die
spd zumindest langsam mit und lässt
manchen gar von einem scholz zu träumen
die spd befindet sich auf dem geiste zug
ist im rollen und er wird immer
schneller und deshalb werden wir auch
noch im zustimmung dazu bekommen da bin
ich sicher doch die momentane stärke des
einen fuß auf der schwäche der anderen
laschet und und berbalk mussten
sicherlich durch ihre pannenserien durch
dieses pannen ping pong durch ein tal
der tränen gehen im augenblick ist stolz
der der lachende dritte aufgrund der
panne von laschet und bernburg aber das
kann sich schnell eben wieder ändern sei
es durch altlasten oder eben auch durch
richtungsstreit in der spd der wieder
aufbricht das rennen offen sechs wochen
vor der wahl ist für alle drei das ziel
kanzleramt erreicht erreichbarer
jedenfalls wohl als für andere
das ziel machst
das neue zdf politbarometer kommt dann
ganz ausführlich noch am ende der
sendung und natürlich können sie es auch
auf zdf heute jederzeit online abrufen
die bundesregierung ruft alle deutschen
dazu auf afghanistan zu verlassen und
hat eine rückholaktion gestartet dabei
soll nicht nur botschaftspersonal
sondern auch afghanische ortskräfte
ausgeflogen werden wie viele ist aber
nicht bekannt viel zeit durfte nicht
mehr bleiben um menschen dort
herauszuholen der vormarsch der taliban
ist noch schneller als befürchtet wurde
mehr als die hälfte der
provinzhauptstädte sollen schon in der
hand der sogenannten gotteskrieger sein
heute wurde gemeldet dass sie die auch
wirtschaftlich bedeutende groß stadt
kandahar im süden und die hauptstadt der
provinz helmand lashkar gah erobert
haben und es steht zu befürchten dass es
nicht mehr lange dauert bis zum sturm
auf kabul katrin eigendorf berichtet
sie sind vor den taliban geflohen einige
von ihnen sind um ihr leben gerannt die
frauen die an diesem morgen mitten in
kabul in einem park campieren haben
alles zurückgelassen wir hatten solche
angst wir haben uns nicht einmal mehr
zur toilette heraus getraut aus furcht
dass die taliban uns mitnehmen könnten
die bibel hatte nicht einmal zeit ihren
mann zu begraben der getötet wurde als
die kämpfer ihre heimatstadt kundus
überfielen mit vier kindern hat sie sich
alleine durch geschlagen
wie die verrückten sind wir gelaufen und
nun sind wir hier und haben nicht einmal
etwas zu essen
5000 familien alleine in diesem park
auch in moscheen suchen die geflüchteten
schutz und jeden tag erreichen mehr die
hauptstadt
provisorisch werden sie von freiwilligen
versorgt von der regierung erhalten sie
keine hilfe doch neben der hitze und dem
hunger ist auch die angst dass die
taliban bald auch kabul einnehmen
könnten auch in den botschafts und
regierungsviertel
rechnen sie damit dass die hauptstadt
nicht mehr lange sicher ist auch
deutschland bereitet sich auf den
ernstfall vor
die belegschaft der deutschen botschaft
in kabul in den nächsten tagen auf das
operativ notwendige absolute minimum
reduzieren
wir werden ein krisen unterstützungsteam
sofort nach kabul schicken
das uns dabei hilft die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen zu erhöhen und
die maßnahmen die wir beschlossen haben
auch umzusetzen
die aussenminister beruf die deutschen
staatsbürger auf afghanistan zu
verlassen eine chance auch für sie das
fragen sich die familien die im
sogenannten safe house einem geschützten
gebäude ausharren dass deutsche soldaten
für ortskräfte der bundeswehr und
anderer deutscher organisationen in
kabul eingerichtet haben den ort kräften
sichert der bundesaußenminister jetzt
zügige lösungen zu die botschaft wird
arbeitsfähig bleiben in afghanistan in
kabul und deshalb haben wir uns auch
dazu entschlossen für diejenigen die
noch kein visa haben bei den orts
kräften die visa zukünftig erst in
deutschland zu erteilen das wird die
ausreise beschleunigen 15 familien fast
alle sind aus dem norden geflohen sie
alle hoffen so schnell wie möglich ihr
land verlassen zu können die 29-jährige
hardy hat als journalistin für einen von
deutschland finanzierten radiosender
gearbeitet seit vier wochen bis sie mit
ihrem mann und zwei kindern hier zwei
kinder mussten sie zurücklassen
wenn die taliban die information
bekommen dass es ein safe house voll mit
familien wie uns gibt dann würde das ein
inakzeptables risiko bedeuten ich möchte
nur sicherheit und hoffe dass sie
schnell eine entscheidung treffen werden
dass ich hier bei einer machtübernahme
durch die taliban nicht mehr sicher sein
werden das wissen und das fürchten sie
alle die zeit drängt die taliban rücken
mit jedem tag weiter auf kabul vor
dieser entwicklung in afghanistan haben
sich die botschafter der nato länder
heute zur sonder beratungen getroffen
anne gellinek in brüssel die nato
schaute im grunde ja auch den folgen
ihres eigenen handelns zu
die nato ist von den usa zum abzug aus
afghanistan gezwungen worden und sie ist
jetzt quasi zum zuschauen verdammt weil
sie obwohl sie ein großes militärbündnis
ist ohne die usa nicht über die
notwendigen militärischen fähigkeiten
wie zum beispiel kampfhubschrauber
verfügt um ein land wie afghanistan zu
sichern gleichzeitig gibt es aus dem
nato-bündnis jetzt auch kritik am
amerikanischen partner der britische
verteidigungsminister hat heute laut und
deutlich gesagt was viele europäische
nato partner bisher nur hinter
vorgehaltener hand
verlauten ließen nämlich dass der abzug
der amerikanischen armee dass der
zeitpunkt des abzugs der amerikanischen
armee falsch sei dass er die möglichkeit
eröffne für al qaida sich wieder in
afghanistan festzusetzen und dass er
damit drohe den gesamten afghanistan
einsatz
den ganzen einsatz sozusagen ad absurdum
zu führen
nun auch schon jetzt sieht ist wie viele
menschen versuchen zu fliehen und das
ist doch zumindestens für die
europäischen nato mitglieder aber auch
für die eu und ein thema sein
ja die eu beschäftigt sich mit dem thema
aber mein eindruck ist noch etwas
halbherzig
schon jetzt ist es ja so dass die
zweitgrößte gruppe aller flüchtlinge die
in europa ankommen afghanen sind und
noch diese woche hat die eu-kommission
uns vorgerechnet wie gut die rückführung
die freiwillige rückführung von afghanen
funktioniere man arbeite sehr gut mit
der afghanischen regierung zusammen also
noch sei die lage entspannt aber klar
ist ja auch dass die afghanische
regierung möglicherweise gar nicht mehr
lange im amt ist und dann gab es noch
zahlen dass eine halbe million afghanen
sich in den nächsten tagen auf den weg
machen könnten und die hoffnung ist dass
die europäische union diesmal besser
vorbereitet ist als im sommer 2015
dankeschön einem für die einschätzung
aus brüssel und wir gehen zurück nach
deutschland noch gut sechs wochen sind
es ja bis zur bundestagswahl bei der
dann auch das umstrittene neue wahlrecht
zum tragen kommt und mit dem thema
beginnen jetzt die nachrichten von
hundelshausen die wahlrechtsreform von
union und spd bleibt zur bundestagswahl
am 26 september in kraft das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat einen
eilantrag abgewiesen mit dem fdp grüne
und linke die änderungen mit sofortiger
wirkung kippen wollten die reform soll
nun im hauptverfahren genau geprüft
werden um die problematik der
überhangmandate anzugehen
ziel der seit langem diskutierten
wahlrechtsreform ist eine verkleinerung
des bundestages
die bundesregierung hofft auf höheres
corona impf tempo nach der ferienzeit in
baden württemberg hamburg und sachsen
sind die impfzahlen in dieser woche
bereits leicht gestiegen mittlerweile
sind laut gesundheitsministerium
47 millionen menschen in deutschland
vollständig geimpft das sind
56,6 prozent der bevölkerung
seit jahresbeginn ist das alter der
korona positiven menschen deutlich
gesunken von durchschnittlich 49 auf 28
jahre zudem steigen die infektionszahlen
gerade bei jugendlichen und jungen
erwachsenen stark bei den 15 bis 24
jährigen liegt die inzidenz derzeit bei
knapp 60 das robert koch institut meldet
5578 neuinfektionen
2130 mehr als vor einer woche 19
menschen starben im zusammenhang mit 19
die sieben tage incidents liegt nun bei
30,1 wegen steigender infektionszahlen
stuft die bundesregierung die türkei als
hochrisiko gebiet ein ab dienstag müssen
einreisende nicht geimpfte und nicht
genesene für bis zu zehn tage in
quarantäne
schon ab sonntag werden die usa israel
und montenegro ebenfalls auf die liste
gesetzt
in der türkei ist die zahl der
todesopfer durch die massiven
überschwemmungen auf 31 gestiegen
heftige regenfälle haben mehrere orte im
norden der türkei unter wasser gesetzt
erdrutsche und fluten zerstörten auch
brücken viele menschen werden vermisst
mehr als 1700 mussten ihre häuser
verlassen
mittlerweile sind 5.000 einsatzkräfte an
den rettungsarbeiten beteiligt
während sich in vielen waldbrandregionen
im mittelmeerraum die lage leicht
entspannt sind auf eur erneut feuer
ausgebrochen
diesmal im süden der griechischen insel
auch algerien und italien kämpfen weiter
gegen zahlreiche brände nach der
rekordhitze von knapp 50 grad in
süditalien entzündeten sich östlich von
rom erneut brandherde zahlreiche orte
wurden evakuiert in ganz italien und auf
sizilien kämpfen die feuerwehren gegen
rund 500 brände
der dreizehnte august gehört zu den
düsteren daten im geschichtsbuch der
deutschen der tag an dem vor 60 jahren
der mauer begann ein perfides bauwerk
das menschen einsperrt an den menschen
ihr leben verloren und das auf bizarre
weise das gesicht einer ganzen stadt
prägte bis diese mauer endlich wieder
viel in berlin wurde heute daran
erinnert wie 1961 die sperren errichtet
und stacheldraht ausgerollt wurde
bundespräsident steinmeier nannte die
mauer ein zeugnis hoffnungslosen
scheiterns der sprache der gedenkstätte
bernauer straße eine der wenigen
berliner orte wo noch mauerteile zu
sehen sind vor allem sind es aber die
erinnerungen und geschichten einzelner
menschen die einen die schrecken dieser
zeit immer wieder vor augen führen zwei
solcher zeit zeugen hat katrin lindner
getroffen
gino cool feilt an einem mahnmal in
cottbus für die toten der flucht mit 20
jahren kommt der gebürtige
baden-württemberger nach west-berlin und
schließt sich fluchthelfern an erst
übernimmt der bodendienste nach
ostberlin dann will er selbst ddr bürger
über die innerdeutsche grenze schmuggeln
die flucht über die mauer mitte der 70er
lebensgefährlich wir haben
große anzahl von menschen die an der
berliner mauer versucht haben zu fliehen
und die sich ja bei 99 prozent und die
schief gegangen mal dies ist ein
brutales im bollwerk
eine lüge am 13 august geschieht das was
viele schon befürchtet haben die ddr
zieht die mauer hoch um west berlin
ein ganzes volk wird eingesperrt wer
kann versucht in den ersten tagen noch
die flucht doch es wird immer
schwieriger
schon 1952 beginnt die ddr die
innerdeutsche grenze massiv zu sichern
auch die anderen sozialistischen länder
schließen den eisernen vorhang
1961 ein weiterer schritt der
abschottung im jahr 1961 bis zum august
sind es ja noch über 200.000 die
versuchen in den westen zu fliehen das
ist zum schluss nur noch über berlin
möglich und dieses letzte schlupfloch in
den westen das wird am 13 august 1960
gestoppt minogue und trifft jürgen
hannemann der cottbuser hat an der mauer
seinen bruder verloren axel hahnemann er
ist froh dass an ihn erinnert wird
1962 weder 17 jährige über die spree
nach west berlin fliehen und wird von
einem grenzsoldaten erschossen warum er
flieht schreibt er im abschiedsbrief
will er sagen bennet drüben ist
trotzdem ist es passiert und leider nur
noch geschichte 159 jahre her aber es
tut immer noch weh hielten sich das
problem für mich bei seiner ersten
fluchthilfe ist gino kuhn bereits im
visier der stasi als sie ihn mit drei
flüchtlingen im kofferraum an der
innerdeutschen grenze fast es folgt
stasi untersuchungshaft in cottbus
isolationszelle ein halbes jahr dann das
urteil sechs jahre gefängnis und das
schlimmste augenblick war eigentlich als
ich mit den ddr bürgern im kofferraum
anging grenzübergang bares zu hause
gekommen bin und ich habe gemerkt die
flucht gelingt nicht und an sich dann
verhaftet wurde mit handschellen und die
bürger aus dem kofferraum gebracht
wurden da wurde mir klar jetzt hast du
so viel einsatz und die andere männchen
natürlich auch alles gewagt und es hat
nicht geklappt sein mahnmal steht im hof
des ehemaligen cottbuser gefängnis in
dem viele ddr-flüchtlinge saßen gino
kuhn wurde nach zweieinhalb jahren frei
gekauft was aus seinen drei flüchtlingen
geworden ist weiß er bis heute nicht
ein gewichtiger zeitzeuge der die
deutsche geschichte selbst mit geprägt
hat ist gestorben kurt biedenkopf er
wurde 91 jahre alt hat krieg und flucht
erlebt die deutsche teilung und
schließlich den mauerfall als erster
ministerpräsident von sachsen nach der
wiedervereinigung war er eine der
führenden köpfe in dieser zeit gewaltige
umbrüche
doch nicht nur in sachsen wird um kurt
biedenkopf getrauert stefan pelz blickt
zurück auf das leben dieses
herausragenden und auch streitbaren
deutschen politiker
der wiederaufbau der frauenkirche war
auch sein werk würdiger ort also für den
neunzigsten geburtstag eines politikers
den viele sachsen respektvoll könig kurt
nannten sachsen und bieten kopf schienen
füreinander bestimmt es war eine zeit
der begegnung
zwischen für mich zwischen zwei welten
und dass es gelungen ist die so
zusammenzuführen dass es vertrauen sich
gebildet hat das land sich entwickeln
konnte die menschen mitgemacht haben
anfang der 90er jahre sehnen sich die
sachsen nach einer figur die das land
aus die mensa arbeitslosigkeit führen
auswege aus den chaotischen ddr
hinterlassenschaften weisen kann und
kontakte hat zu investoren biedenkopf
scheint einer zu sein und er trifft im
wahlkampf offenbar den ton den die
sachsen hören wollen und verstehen
können
[Musik]
nicht
biedenkopfs karriere ein spiegel seiner
charaktereigenschaften er ist eitel klug
visionär elitär dies beschert ihm nach
jedem aufstieg auch immer wieder
politische abstiege legendäres beispiel
der damalige generalsekretär mag den
aufstand gegen die machtfülle helmut
kohls und verliert erst in sachsen
betritt wieder die politische bühne holt
für die cdu zehn jahre lang absolute
mehrheiten wenn man nicht aus sachsen
kam warum man manchmal schon ganz
bedrückt weil man nicht ganz so stolz
sein konnte aber gut die sachsen und die
mecklenburger ist wie so ein langes
kapitel auch in der zeit der friedlichen
revolution stand auf den zügen schlaft
ruhig weiter also sein forsches vorgehen
birgt aber auch fallen in den medien
kursieren anfang der 2000er jahre
mutmaßungen über eine vetternwirtschaft
von biedenkopfs gnaden das
fingerspitzengefühl für die brisanz der
situation fehlt ihm völlig 2002 ist
bieten kopf zeit als spitzenpolitiker
vorbei er ist 72 aber in sachsen
beginnen viele landschaften tatsächlich
zu blühen er war visionär und macher
er träumte vom wiederaufbau der
frauenkirche und vom silicon saxony
sachsen als herzstück moderner
technologien mit der beginn seiner
amtszeit
verbindet mich alles was sicherlich die
meisten sachsen verbunden hat hoffnung
das richtige mann an der spitze ist und
das war er ja was besseres hätte ja gar
nicht passieren kann das war eigentlich
der mann auch von seiner ausstrahlung
gehabt war
das beste was sachsen passieren konnte
ich würde biedenkopf ein denkmal hier in
sachsen errichten zuspruch freute ihn
stets doch zufriedenheit war für kurt
biedenkopf keine option ich
interpretiere beim begriff
zufrieden etwas zurückhaltend denn wenn
man anfängt zufrieden zu sein
dann fällt aber auch nichts mehr ein
warum mach kurt biedenkopfs
lebensleistung ein historischer
glücksfall für sachsen
aus anlass seines todes sendet das zdf
nachher um 0 uhr noch eine
ausführlichere doku über das lebenswerk
von gekommen
und jetzt nochmal gundula zunächst mit
dem blick auf die deutsche wirtschaft an
der frankfurter börse kam ist zu diesem
wochenschluss zu zwei größeren
ereignissen der dax ist zum ersten mal
über die marke von 16.000 punkten
gesprungen und der finanzsektor war
heute ziel einer fridays for future demo
in frankfurt mit der forderung planet
vor profit sina mainitz der klimawandel
ist ja bereits thema auch der
finanzmärkte wie kam denn die proteste
an der börse an also hier am parkett hat
man die kurse beobachtet und vor der
börse die turbulenzen im frankfurter
bankenviertel haben nach polizeiangaben
rund 4500 aktivisten von friday future
demonstriert wenn die erde eine bank
wäre hättet ihr sie schon längst
gerettet hieß es da mit
milliardenschweren investitionen in
klimaschädliche energieträger wie öl
oder kohle treiber der finanzsektor die
erderwärmung weiter voran das volumen
nachhaltiger geldanlagen ist 2009 10 auf
2020 um mehr als ein drittel gestiegen
vergangenes jahr machten sie aber immer
noch nur 64 prozent des gesamten
deutschen form marktes aus nach wie vor
handelt es sich um eine nische
langfristig gesehen werden sich grüne
anlagen aber durchsetzen in
klimafreundliche produkte wird
investiert nur nachhaltige firmen sind
zukunfts und wettbewerbsfähig und können
arbeitsplätze sichern ja über die
nachhaltigkeit steigender börsenkurse
wird ja oft spekuliert der dax hat heute
erstmals in seiner geschichte die 16.000
punkte marke geknackt am ende dann ein
stand von 15
1977 gute quartalszahlen und
konjunkturspritzen der notenbanken
sorgen für das plus nächste woche könnte
die euphorie aber etwas ausgebremst
werden dafür aber erst einmal ein gutes
wochenende danke sie nahm ebenso danke
für die deutschen beachvolleyballerinnen
gibt es bei den europameisterschaften in
wien weiter hoffnung auf eine medaille
von denen gleich drei teams im
viertelfinale kam eines durch karla
borger und julia sude mit dem
angriffsschlag bürger hier zum ersten
satzgewinn gegen das ebenfalls stark
spielenden russische doppel da bücher
und kohle mine und der match bald zum 21
zu 19 morgen ist halbfinale und eine
medaille für die beiden düsseldorfer
rinnen zum greifen nahe
und dann kommen wir wieder zum
politischen wettbewerb das neue zdf
politbarometer war ja am anfang der
sendung schon thema alle fragen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen und alle
ergebnisse präsentiert ihnen jetzt
matthias fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
mit der rekord summe von 30 milliarden
euro wollen bund und länder helfen die
katastrophengebiete in rheinland-pfalz
und nordrhein-westfalen wieder
aufzubauen und den menschen eine
perspektive zu geben nach dem
zerstörerischen hochwasser vor vier
wochen ist noch lange keine normalität
eingekehrt gerade im aartal ist die
infrastruktur massiv beschädigt
vielerorts fehlt fließend wasser auch
die verschmutzungen durch öl bereitet
sorgen tausende menschen helfen jeden
tag die politik handelt die kritik am
krisenmanagement aber bleibt eine
mehrheit der befragten in ganz
deutschland ist skeptisch
dass für die opfer der
hochwasserkatastrophe genug getan wird
finden 35% 40%
bezweifeln dass die 25 prozent sind sich
unsicher
die fähigkeit in krisen schnell und
kompetent zu handeln sollte wohl zum
repertoire eines künftigen
bundeskanzlers oder einer kanzlerin
zählen und nicht allen kandidaten
scheinen die deutschen das zuzutrauen
armin laschet ministerpräsident in
nordrhein westfalen und unions
spitzenkandidat entziehen jedenfalls
immer mehr menschen das vertrauen der
trend des letzten politbarometers setzt
sich fort
nur noch 28 prozent
laschet für kanzlertauglich
olaf scholz von der spd traut dagegen
eine mehrheit von 59 prozent das amt zu
annalena baerbock von den grünen nur
noch 23 prozent
vor zwei wochen hielten laschet noch 35
prozent für geeignet scholz 54% und
baerbock 25 prozent
scholz enteilt also der strauchelnden
konkurrenz das zeigt sich auch beim
direktvergleich zum allerersten mal
überhaupt sehen wir da einen klaren
vorsprung für einen der drei kandidaten
21 prozent hätten am liebsten einen
kanzler laschet ein deutliches minus von
8 punkten im vergleich zur letzten
umfrage
44 prozent würden sich scholz wünschen
plus 10 und nur 16 prozent der burg - 4
19 prozent können sich da nicht
entscheiden
schwere zeiten für armin laschet und
annalena baerbock das belegt auch unsere
top ten hier die beliebtesten
politikerinnen und politiker sortiert
nach sympathie und leistung auf der
skala von +5 bis -5
schlusslicht annalena baerbock minus 0,4
leicht verbessert davor armin laschet
minus 0,3 etwas schlechter platz acht
für christian lindner 0,2 davor jens
spahn 0,3 etwas besser dann horst
seehofer 0,3 leicht verschlechtert auf
platz 5 heiko maas 0,7 schlechter robert
habeck 1,1 platz drei für markus söder
1,3 etwas schlechter auf platz 2 olaf
scholz 1,4 besser an der spitze angela
merkel 2,5 leicht verschlechtert von den
köpfen zu den parteien und da gibt es
einiges an bewegung in der projektion
wenn am nächsten sonntag wirklich
bundestagswahl wäre dann könnte die
union nur noch mit 26 prozent rechnen
minus 2 die spd bei 19 prozent plus 3
ihr bester wert im politbarometer seit 4
drei jahren die afg 11 unverändert auch
die fdp 11 plus 1 die linke unverändert
bei 7 prozent die grünen bei 19 prozent
minus 2
damit hätte kein zweiter bündnis eine
mehrheit sei schwarz-grün müsste die fdp
mit ins boot jamaica versuch nummer zwei
stünde dann an auch andere
dreierbündnisse gingen beispielsweise
eine ampel aus grünen spd und fdp oder
auch die sogenannte deutschland
koalition aus union spd und fdp
kommen wir zum thema corona im bund und
länder haben bei ihrem treffen am
dienstag einige änderungen auf den weg
gebracht unter anderem sollen corona
tests ab mitte oktober
kostenpflichtig werden für menschen die
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen drei
viertel der befragten finden das richtig
22 prozent nicht deutliche zustimmung in
allen politischen lagern außer bei den
anhängern der afd
rund zwei drittel der befragten sind
dafür dass geimpfte und genesene in
zukunft mit weniger beschränkungen leben
dürfen als nicht geimpfte weniger als
ein drittel ist dagegen
geht es um den lieblingssport der
deutschen den fußball dann sagen die
meisten den sollten schon möglichst
viele im stadion erleben können zum
start der fußball bundesliga haben wir
gefragt wer dort als zuschauer
zugelassen werden soll
30 prozent sagen dass sollten nur
geimpfte und genesene seien 49 prozent
finden auch getestete nicht geimpfte
sollten rein dürfen nur 15 prozent sind
dafür die spiele vor leeren rängen
auszutragen
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur mitte
und zu den qualitätsstandards finden sie
unter politbarometer punkt zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann am
27 august nach dem wetter geht's hier
heiter weiter mit queens of comedy ihnen
noch einen entspannten abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend am wochenende hält das hoch
elfi noch durch aber dann zehn tiefs
heran und die nehmen eine relative
südliche bahn und deswegen wird es bei
uns nächste woche deutlich wechselhafter
und auch kühler regenfälle gibt es
allerdings auch schon in dieser nacht
hier an der nordseeküste über den süden
ziehen einige schauer und gewitter
hinweg in der mitte aber da gibt es oft
strahlend den sternenhimmel und deswegen
wird es dort auch am kühlsten mit 15 bis
10 grad in diesem dreieck ulm passau
regensburg bleibt am mildesten mit 19
grad die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen in norddeutschland bei 20 bis 25
grad südlich von bonn kassel und berlin
geht's auf 26 bis 31 grad auf für die
meisten von uns wird das morgen ein sehr
freundlicher sommertag nur in
norddeutschland sind die wolken dichter
und bringen etwas regen mit und am
nachmittag drohen dann einzelne
hitzegewitter in süddorf schatz an
diesem wetter ändert sich auch am
sonntag noch wenig in norddeutschland
allerdings wird es stärker bewölkt sein
da fällt dann häufiger regen und die
gewittergefahr in süddeutschland nimmt
etwas zu am sonntag liegen die
höchsttemperaturen noch mal bei 20 bis
31 grad aber danach stürzen sie
regelrecht ab mitte nächster woche
liegen die höchstwerte nur noch zwischen
16 und maximal 22 grad und dazu wird das
wetter auch deutlich wechselhafter
regenschauer und gewitter gibt es vor
allen dingen in norddeutschland aber
nicht nur dort